what is up people of the internet
it is I
your favorite person
and fearless leader Ethan Klein today
I'm joined by Avi Loeb
yes
world renowned
professor of science at Harvard
University
700 research articles
how do you what's how do you do that
I work 24 7. really you hard worker yeah
but um science was not my favorite
subject when I was a kid
I grew up on a farm I collected eggs
every afternoon wait are you are you a
um oh a moshab that's like a village
where each family owns its own Farm okay
and kibbutz is where you share
everything including your family members
is that right wow so did we do that no
no so I grew up on the moshav and
I worked in the farm and on weekends I
would drive the tractor to the hills of
the village and read philosophy books I
was interested curious about the most
important questions about our life and
that's that was inspired by my mother
um and then and then I made a compromise
because in Israel you have to serve in
the military at the age of 18 and yes I
was recruited to a special program that
allowed me to study Physics and
Mathematics that was my compromise the
closest I could get to philosophy the
the love of my childhood My First Love
and then eventually
um I proposed that was the time of Star
Wars of the initiative of Ronald Reagan
and we were the first project funded
by Star Wars and I came to I mean we got
a few million dollars a year and I I
came to during my military service I
came to
um Washington DC and in one of the
visits
um I was introduced to
um
uh Princeton New Jersey where um Albert
Einstein spent the last two decades of
his life and it's the institute for
advanced studying I visited the place
and eventually I was offered a five-year
Fellowship there after I finished my
military
service to
study astrophysics that was the
condition I didn't know anything I
didn't know how the Sun Shines and
person who recruited me uh made a gamble
um what made them think that you would
be good at that if you had no experience
in mathematics and such well his name
was John bakal and he was married to an
Israeli just like okay yes yes and um uh
he checked about me now during my
military service I we went through all
the military the Army sections so I
parachuted three times jumped off an
airplane
have you done anything more extreme
since then or is that the peak of your
extreme I was so they asked me whether I
want to be part of um a Delta Force kind
of in Israel a very special unit because
I was good then athletically I mean I
was among the three top high school
students in sports when I you know among
a thousand or so
um but
it looked to me like intellectual work
is much more appealing than physical and
so I ended up
at Princeton eventually
and then after five years there I was
over the position at Harvard uh even
though
people decline this position because the
chance of getting tenure were very small
and the previous person was two decades
earlier and wow um so then eventually I
got tenure there and then I realized
that this arranged marriage I it felt
like an arranged marriage I didn't
really want to do astrophysics but then
it looked like it's the love of my life
because it addresses philosophical
questions like how did the universe
start
what was there at the beginning you know
these are questions in the first uh
chapter of Genesis the Bible I mean
people thought about them it's it's very
important to people and then are we
alone you know that's not the question
from a dating app as I try to clarify
yesterday I was in Las Vegas there was a
special
conference uh world leader leadership
conference by the international women's
Forum I was with 800 women it was is
that that what happens in Vegas does not
stay in Vegas yes so I assume you guys
were not talking about chlamydia
something more scientific so what that's
what I said at the end because I was
asked what would be the implications if
we find evidence for a smarter kid on
our block you know like another
civilization and I said
you know what happens in Vegas does not
stay in Vegas everything we discussed
here will eventually affect everyone you
know Humanity because there are many
implications to finding a higher
intelligence well one first I should
clarify that the reason I seek
intelligence out there is because I
don't often find it here
uh but uh in terms of implications you
know if you look at human history it's
shaped very often by groups of people
trying to feel Superior relative to
other people and if we realize that
there is a smarter species out there uh
it will convince us that the small
differences among us are really
meaningless you think so you never have
that profoundly effect I think so and
and we would feel as equal members of
the human species that's what I think
because think about it like
discrimination based on the color of a
skin that that makes zero sense like
what does that have to do with the
ability of a person to think to do
things and that seems still to be an
issue that people yeah and so you know I
think that once we realize that we are
just
one out of many you know that in fact we
know that there are billions of stars
out there okay and we know that a
significant fraction of them have a
planet like the Earth roughly the same
separation
so the dice was rolled billions of times
and most likely we are not the smartest
most likely there was a scientist
smarter than Albert Einstein on another
planet a billion years ago because most
most of those stars formed 10 billion
years ago and the sun formed only 4.6
billion years ago by the way the sun
within one billionaire will boil off all
the oceans on Earth we would not be able
to stay here that's all we've got that's
all we've got it's about we had more
than that no uh [ __ ]
the point is the other stars already
went through that because there are five
billion years older so all the
Earth-like planets around those sun-like
Stars most of them you know you got you
have a clock you gotta go you have it
and the Clock Was ticking and perhaps
most civilizations have ever lived
predated us and they could have sent
probes into space and those probes could
have reached Us by now because it takes
less than a billion years to go across
the Milky Way galaxy and by the way for
70 years we were looking for radio
signals and that's just like waiting at
home for a phone call
you wait and wait and you don't hear a
phone call because maybe nobody is
around to call you the point is there is
another way instead of that you can
search your mailbox for any packages
that accumulated over time in the
mailbox so any spacecraft that was
launched by chemical Rockets
would never be able to escape from the
gravitational pull of the Milky Way so
it's like a basket collecting all of the
spacecrafts and you know some of them
may be near us some of them may have
passed near the Earth some functional
devices may be hovering around the earth
these are potentially unidentified
aerial phenomena my point is it's not a
philosophical question to find out we
just need to look up but we have been
and you would think that if they're like
you said there's like I don't know in
the Milky Way there's like 200 billion
stars approximately or something like
that right so if you know there is it
turns out tens of thousands or millions
of alien civilizations
I mean
like is it not likely that we would have
saw something already a probe or a sign
or a ship or a radio signal or something
well space is vast so
you have to understand that um only over
the past decade we had telescopes that
can see objects the size of a football
field the size of a football field
passing within the orbit of the Earth
around the Sun only over the past decade
and
we discovered four
objects so far that over the past decade
that came into the solar system from
outside these are called Interstellar
objects the first three are really weird
the first two were meteors roughly the
size of a watermelon and they collided
with Earth and burnt up in the
atmosphere that's what a meteor is
basically with the friction
that you know with the air it it
basically explodes so the first one in
2014 January 2014 exploded a hundred
miles off the coast of Papua New Guinea
and the government has missile Warning
Systems so it detected the Fireball and
with my student we calculated that this
object was moving so fast at 45
kilometers per second that it couldn't
have been bound to the Sun to the solar
system and it came from outside now what
was strange about it well at first my
colleague said we don't believe the US
government so they didn't accept the
paper we submitted for publication why
are you representing the US government
no we just found it in a public data set
that the government compiled of meteors
okay so the government is monitoring for
ballistic missiles so you know they're
saying the data you used is unreliable
no they said the government did not
release how uncertain the data is and
obviously the government would not do
that because it doesn't want adversaries
to be aware of the sensors like for
example the uh that's how you guys
figured out the speed yeah but the
question was is it uncertain and I said
you know the government needs to know
whether ballistic missile hits
Washington DC or Boston you know it
needs to have very high Precision so
what my colleagues are saying the
government doesn't know what it's doing
doesn't make any sense because it's for
national security purposes and these are
satellites that is it that hard to
believe is that why they're reluctant to
no they just don't trust the government
data no they just want to stick to
studying rocks
so you know experts that worked for
decades on rocks space rocks yeah want
everything in the sky to be space rocks
right that came from because
all of the Rocks studied so far came
from the solar system there are so many
meteors that are rocks left over from
the construction project of the planets
you know of the solar system these are
just like Lego pieces left but one in a
thousand are things that came from
outside the solar system and this was
the first one and when the government
three years later in March this year
they released a letter from the
Department of Defense the U.S space
command confirming at the 99.99 percent
that my student and I were correct and
then our paper was accepted for
publication just recently and I should
say now as a result of that I said let's
go and have an expedition to scoop the
ocean floor for the fragments of this
meteor because the government also
released the fireball data how much
light was emitted from when the object
burnt up as a result of friction with
the atmosphere with the air and from
that we infer that the object was
tougher than iron
so it was tougher than
272 other objects in the Qatar all of
them in the catalog so what was it was
it a rock of some unusual composition or
was it a spacecraft made of an alloy
like stainless steel you know we so we
decided to establish an expedition that
will scoop the ocean floor
and within a month or two after
announcing that I received full funding
one and a half million dollars who does
that come from I was wondering just
private interested folks or yeah in this
case two people
um not well known it's not Jeff Bezos or
Elon Musk although I would love to get
yeah if you guys are watching obvious
and they're open but I didn't do any
fundraising the point is these people
approached me and I should say since my
book extraterrestrial came out a year
and a half ago there were many
interesting people that visited the
porch of my home near Boston a few
multi-billionaires that gave me about
four Bill four million dollars that
allowed me to establish a whole project
called the Galileo project we can talk
more about it but this Expedition will
move forward within half a year we'll go
there and we will scoop the ocean floor
look look for the fragments that made
this meteor and try to infer whether it
was a natural rock or some artificial
alloy of an an object and already
promised uh
Antonelli she's the
um curator of the Museum of Modern Art
in New York City but if we find a gadget
at the bottom of the ocean near Papua
New Guinea I'll put it on display
at the Museum of Modern Art because for
us it would represent modernity even
though for the senders it's ancient
history they sent it a billion years ago
or something yeah and you would think
that it's probably if it were of
extraterrestrial origin it would be like
a probe or something like that yeah it
could be dysfunctional that's why it
crashed into Earth so just think about
Voyager or New Horizons this spacecraft
that we launched that will exit the
solar system in a billion years they
might collide with another planet right
and the question is what will the
astronomers on that planet do make us so
many of them would say oh it's a rock
forget about it it's not worth putting
the money into looking into it but maybe
one can I ask you is it that is it so um
extraordinary to have objects
Interstellar objects entering into our
solar system no it's not unusual it's
the first one that we noticed it's the
first one the only one we've ever
observed not the only the first the
first from 2 2014 then in 2017 there was
a second meteor also tougher than iron
and we this one landed not far from
Portugal that will be our next
Expedition so is it just because
um the technology has enabled us to
detect that yeah we're coming from so in
this case both meteors were discovered
from the fireball that they created and
which was comparable you know to the
energy releasing an atomic explosion
okay so the satellites that the
government owns saw it
so both of them were roughly meter in
size half a meter to a meter
but the only reason we started detecting
them over the past decade is because the
government put satellites and sensors
that are sensitive to that so it's
relatively common we just have not seen
it before because we didn't put these
detectors and you know in Rico Fermi 70
years ago asked where is everybody you
know so it's just like sitting on the
sofa at home and saying where are my
neighbors I don't see anyone around me
well guess what to find them you need to
look through the windows and you better
use telescopes so for the first time the
past decade we started looking through
the windows now the third object was
discovered by a telescope in Hawaii
called pan stars and it was about the
size of a football field it didn't
collide with the Earth so we just saw
the reflection of sunlight from it and
that's why it needed to be so big you're
talking about
yes that's an artist yeah an artist we
don't have a by the way if we had a
that's what I really want to have a
photo on this right of such an object
because a picture is worth a thousand
words in my case it's worth 66 000 words
the number of words in my book I won't
write the book it's much easier to show
a photo album you know that's what I
really want because yeah what interested
you so much about this object it's just
you know a space rock floating through
our solar system I mean what's
significant about that well that's what
I thought first I should say a decade
before that I wrote a paper saying let's
figure out whether we would see any
space rocks based on what we know about
the solar system so we predicted none
will be observed by the telescope in
Hawaii so the fact that they detected it
already says that there are many more
space objects that enter the solar
system than we thought beforehand
this next was
the properties of this object looked
really strange it was stumbling every
eight hours and the amount of sunlight
that was reflected from the object
Changed by a factor of 10. so that means
the area of the object projected
on the sky changed by a factor of tennis
it was tumbling so just like a piece
imagine a piece of paper tumbling in the
wind even though it's razor thin it's
very thin piece of paper
the area for the area to change by a
factor of 10 it really needs to be
extremely thin as it moves around
because it's not always it's not Edge on
it's unlikely to be Edge on
so that already meant the object has an
extreme shape and someone tried to fit
the variation of light and derived that
it's it must be pancake like flat which
is very unusual for space rocks and then
the thing that so every time a new
revelation came it looked more and more
weird to me and I said maybe it's a
technological Relic as soon as this
started to appear so then uh another
group and all of these are reports by
astronomers you know mainstream
astronomers another group realized that
it was pushed away from the Sun by some
Force
so usually you can get a push like that
if you have a comet if there is
evaporation and just like in a Jet Plane
you know the when you throw uh the The
Vapor one way it pushes the object the
other way so that's how a jet plane goes
you know there is gas flowing through
the exhaust in in a direction and then
it pushes also Rockets follow that so
that's how comets get propelled by the
evaporation from sunlight hitting the
surface but there was no commentary tail
a comet is very easy to see because you
get a tale of dust and gas around it but
there was nothing you couldn't see
anything the speed of Space Telescope
looked very deeply and didn't see any
evidence for dust or gas
so then what was pushing it so the only
explanation I could think of is that
it's very thin
like like a sale except it's not pushed
by the wind it's pushed by reflecting
sunlight
and I wrote it in a paper
and then it was accepted for publication
within a few days but then there was a
huge pushback from the scientific
Community because I said nature doesn't
make that it may be artificial maybe a
sale a light sail or maybe a surface
layer that was torn apart from a bigger
craft you know or maybe it's a leaflet
that has a message for our Salvation
like a letter in our mailbox who knows
what it is maybe it's a Mothership that
released them you know
probes just like the DeLeon seeds you
know yeah um I remember when it came out
there was lots of excitement and then it
seemed that it was overwhelmed by
skepticism yes so what do you make of
the
the skepticism of your contemporaries
for this kind of uh search or
fascination with visitors to our solar
system right because that does exist
right right you're probably at odds with
the majority of your contemporary well I
don't have any footprint on social media
when I got married my wife asked me
don't have any and so I said okay yeah
she was smart it was a while yeah a
while ago and now I recognize him uh so
I don't need to buy Twitter I just avoid
eight dollars a month that's all it's
gonna no I mean 44 billion I don't need
to to put 44 billion just to silence
yeah yeah what people say about me yeah
you know I just don't subscribe to it
it's very cheap
um and so
um
you know in science we don't have the
luxury of ignoring evidence
this is the realm of politics in
politics you can ignore evidence you can
say oh no you can invent your own
reality you can live in a bubble but in
science it's not allowed is that what
you think your colleagues are doing
though because they would they would
probably say the same thing about Euro
now no no no
they did pay attention to the evidence
okay I'm saying it you're not allowed to
ignore it so they didn't ignore it
what did they propose a section an
explanation for the evidence okay
so there were about half a dozen papers
trying to explain it okay so first
there was a group of people that said
we know it's natural
period and that was published in a very
prestigious journal Nature astronomy so
a group of experts came together and
announced that it must be natural
so then everyone said okay well if these
experts say that it must wait a second
like and then a few months later
a team suggested oh well but there is
this push how do we explain it so then
they said well maybe it's a hydrogen
Iceberg a chunk of Frozen hydrogen we've
never seen anything like it before it
cannot be produced in a system like the
solar system it must have been produced
in a completely different setup like a
molecular cloud or something we've never
seen it but it's a chunk of Frozen
hydrogen the size of a football field
gets evaporated and then we don't see
the hydrogen because it's transparent
so I worked out with a colleague of mine
showing that it would evaporate very
quickly because hydrogen evaporates
quickly and it won't survive the journey
so the authors of this paper agreed with
us and said okay well that's a problem
so then another group said maybe it's a
cloud of dust particles a hundred times
less dense than air so it's very fluffy
and when it reflects sunlight it gets
pushed the problem with that is when it
gets close to the Sun it will not
maintain its Integrity disintegrate so
then a third team three three months
later just to remind you all of this
came after the first group of experts
said it must be natural now if it was
obvious that it's natural why did all
the others have to invent all kinds
anyway so the third group said oh it's a
nitrogen iceberg a chunk of a chip of
Frozen nitrogen that was chipped off the
surface of a planet like Pluto so then
we wrote a paper showing that if you
take all the solid nitrogen in
pluto-like planets in the Milky Galaxy
you just don't get enough chips to
explain a big enough population that
would account for a more
but anyway all of these possibilities
buy the mainstream people that didn't
ignore the evidence all of them invoke
a rock of a type that we've never seen
before so to me it reminds me of cave
dwellers that are used to playing with
rocks and when they see a cell phone
they would say the cell phone is a rock
of a type that we've never seen before
right and how would they find that it's
not a rock by pressing a button that
records their voice so my point is
this is intriguing enough for us to
collect more evidence sure rather than
saying it's natural period let's move on
we should say it's intriguing let's
collect more data on the next
and you know it's just like dating uh we
want to in in the Galileo project that I
lead we want to run the Vu with the next
and there is a dating app
it's called the Vera Rubin observatory
in Chile that will start operations in a
year
and it will identify many more objects
like
most of the time we will swipe to the
left
love the analogy yeah powerful
yeah I mentioned it yesterday in front
of 800 women and um yeah yeah they
laughed good uh I you know I'm always
warned by my daughters and my wife not
to make jokes about dating Ah that's
your specialty as far as I'm aware
so I don't listen to them because I do
get the Applause yeah yeah anyway
um but the point is that every now and
then we'll see a weird object
and we would like to come close to it to
get a photograph because as I said you
know we should pay attention to evidence
especially if it's intriguing rather
than dismissing it right uh I mean the
reason that experts on space rocks want
everything in the sky to look like a
space Rock and be natural is because
they base their reputation on studies of
space rocks and they don't want anything
new one of them you know there was a
lecture about Harvard and when I left
the room he said he told me is so weird
I wish it never existed
well you know that's not unusual in
scientific Community whenever there's
been huge uh breakthroughs there's
there's always people who are resistant
to
um you know adjusting their world view
and that that that happens every time
this is a major adjustment I think it
would be the most important discovery of
humanity because just think about the
implications you know like suppose we
find the gadget that represents our
future that will take us a million years
to develop it would look like magic
uh an advanced extraterrestrial
civilization that has science much more
developed than we developed so far
you know they could look like God
because they can create life in their
Laboratories they could create a baby
Universe in their love you know I
sometimes think that maybe the Big Bang
was created by a scientist in a white
coat somewhere
is that a simulation Theory or no okay
so that's a smaller Universe within a
larger universe theory well in physics
simulations are generated on a computer
okay so they're not real in the sense
that they do you know it's like living
in the metaverse you can have neighbors
in the metaverse you can always look
nice in the metaverse but it's not the
reality that we all share it's like
taking drugs you live in your own thing
in your own world and there is something
to be spoken about the reality we all
share because if we pay attention to
that reality not to the simulation or
simulated reality we can adapt to it
you know we can like if we realize the
the climate is changing we can do things
you know that will mitigate that if we
uh realize that a pandemic is caused by
a virus we can do something about it you
know so knowing what reality is like
even if it's not flattering your ego you
know
it's just like looking at the mirror and
seeing what what is really out there
rather than look living in the metaverse
where you you look like a Brad Pitt all
the time and so I think it's always good
for us to get a sense of reality and the
way to do it is by collecting data and
evidence and and that's what we should
be doing all the time what are the
chances that uh AMU amuwa do you think
is of of uh Alien uh origin if have you
crunched that
it's it's definitely very weird and the
same is true for the first two
Interstellar meteors so my goal is to
get more data and make sure you know
that we understand that you have a hunch
though you have a feeling one where you
just you just want to find out yeah but
you know out of modesty I don't think
that we are
the Pinnacle of creation I don't think
you know I think that we are sort of in
the middle of our class of intelligent
civilization you know when I teach at
Harvard I tell the undergraduates on the
first day I say
half of you in the class are below the
median
and they get upset because because all
the students that get to Harvard think
that they're the smartest but it's a
statistical fact that you know the
median is always in the middle and half
of the class is always behind you know
below it so it's a statistical fact that
in every class irrespective of who is in
the class half of the class is below the
medium and I think of humanity in the
same way I think that it's very unlikely
that we are sort of the best that was
ever created and therefore we should be
modest and just try to learn from our
neighbors rather than argue that there
is nobody out there we are the smartest
you know we for for centuries we argue
that we are at the center of the
universe you know
Aristotle argued that and people
believed him the church believed him and
the reason was simple because it
flattered our ego to think that we are
at the center then we realize now we are
on earth the Earth moves around the sun
the sun moves around the center of the
Milky Way and the Milky Way is just one
out of a trillion galaxies like it in
the universe that is expanding and so we
are not at the center of stage okay
and then we realize oh we just came at
the end of a very long Cosmic play you
know that lasted for 13.8 billion years
since the Big Bang so if you arrive to a
play
just at the end of the play and you are
not at the center of stage
the play is not about you
as much as you want to think that you
are Central like all you know humans
people think that we are really
important we are not
and in order for us to find more about
what the play is
we should seek other actors because they
may have been around and they may know
what the play is about it seems that
you're
um I would say looking over your kind of
career and your work and your focus at
least recently you seem to have a large
emphasis on the search for
extraterrestrial life I want to throw
you as you say that's accurate recently
in the last five years before that I
worked on black holes you know these
extreme structures of space and time
that it's the ultimate prison if you
fall into them you can never check out
by the way I spoke about them to a class
of my daughter when she was young and
um and then one of the kids asked me
what will happen to my body if I fall
into a black hole
so I explained I said look as you get
close to the so-called Singularity at
the center
the tide on your body that you know your
legs will be pulled much more than your
head and you will be torn apart at which
point the teacher said stop speaking
about it because they would have
nightmares so but there is this
fascination with blackouts I worked on
black holes I worked here also at the
sync on the scientific version of the
story of Genesis you know how the first
light was producing the Earth right
right yeah so I want to ask you about
that stuff but first I want to Stephen
Hawking uh I think before he passed
shortly before he had said a lot of
stuff about
the search for aliens being a bad idea
and I'll read you a quote that you can
respond to he said we don't know much
about aliens but we know about humans if
you look at history contact between
humans and less intelligent organisms
has often been disastrous from their
Viewpoint and encounters between
civilizations with Advanced versus
primitive technologies have gone very
badly for Less Advanced the civilization
reading one of our messages could be
billions of years ahead of us if so
there will be vastly more powerful and
may not see us as any more valuable than
we see bacteria okay I
um respectfully disagree but I should
first clarify that in April 2016 Stephen
Hawking came to my home
for Passover dinner
and gave a speech that was the year when
I was the founding director of the black
hole initiative at Harvard so we just
established it and also we announced the
Breakthrough star shot project which is
an initiative to launch a spacecraft
that would reach the nearest star in our
lifetime okay so he came to celebrate
both events and came to my home and it
was a wonderful experience to host him
for three weeks
uh but on this I disagree with him
because just think about it we had our
Science and Technology over the past
Century okay so Quantum Mechanics for
example that we use in our Gadgets in
your cell phone you know that we use in
this recording it's all you know all of
the gadgets that we are using are based
on quantum mechanics okay we discovered
quantum mechanics only 100 years ago it
was not known before that and so
all the advances in modern science and
technology came about over the past
Century and that's one part in a hundred
million
of the age of the Earth or the Sun okay
so that means that the chance of us
meeting another civilization exactly at
the same phase as we are is really small
one part in 100 million okay
and most likely there would either be
much more primitive than we are or much
more advanced because you know for a few
million years we were just
not very sophisticated so to find the
the more primitive ones like we were a
million years ago you have to launch a
spacecraft
board it and then land on another planet
and then start searching through the
trees for those primitive tribes that
represent our past that's very tedious
I don't think we will ever do that okay
to find the more advanced civilizations
you don't need to do anything except
look out because they would reach you by
now and that's what I'm advocating for
let's check so my point about Stephen
Hawking's uh sort of risk assessment is
if they are much more advanced than we
are and it's sort of like a
technological Gap you know so mind the
gap if they are much more advanced than
we are it's just like a biker going down
the sidewalk the biker doesn't care
about ants
in the cracks of the pavement you know
so
you know we might think that we are
important we are Central we are like the
ants we might decide about a protocol
how to engage with a biker and what the
biker will do to us and so forth but the
biker doesn't care less because these
ants are so primitive if they don't pose
a risk to the biker so the biker just
drives through wasn't that kind of his
point though he says uh they may not see
us as anything more valuable than we see
bacteria I remember one of his uh
concerns that he wrote about was that
you know because they see us as so
primitive they would perhaps come to our
planet Harvest our our minerals or our
resources right perhaps use our planet's
resources to build more probes because
yeah it's kind of like you know the uh
Borg from Star Trek or whatever yeah
they could be self-replicated you know
by the way if they are functional they
would probably have artificial
intelligence because we are now on the
cusp of artificial tensions taking over
humans yeah and in our future that
probably will be the case and I think
that our AI I systems would have kinship
to their AI system it's more than to us
in the future yeah okay and we will use
our AI systems to tell us they will be
The Interpreter just like you know Alan
Turing during this the second world war
um
he was he developed Enigma to figure out
the code of the Nazis and he was using
computers for that uh and people mainly
uh in the future we could use our AI
systems in the same way so you you don't
you don't share any of those
apprehensions that that he did
not at all I think we will benefit from
an interaction because we will learn
from them if we are open-minded if we
don't declare ourselves as Superior to
start with you know that's the alpha
male approach
um that will not be stopped by the way
we don't have a protocol how to deal
with a visitor to our backyard
in the past people said what will happen
if we detect a radio signal but it takes
you know tens of thousands of years for
a radio signal to arrive to us from a
distant star within the Milky Way galaxy
so it was thought that we have plenty of
time to think about it but if you have a
visitor just next to you you have to
respond immediately and there is no
organization that represents Humanity
right now and frankly I'm worried about
some crazy guy in the even if there is
an organization someone in the periphery
will do something crazy and engage with
anything but as I said I'm not worried
because I think any Gadget would be far
more advanced and we can
develop and yeah and we'll know how to
deal with it
it seems that you when you're thinking
about extraterrestrials visiting the
planet you're not talking about UFOs and
little green uh there's aliens walking
off the ship it seems like we're talking
about probes and and uh exploratory
tools that an advanced civilization
would be sending out Wellington to ask
what would be their purpose what would
be their goal because you know that will
affect how they interact with us
by the way if you go back a hundred
years there was a very famous
philosopher Martin buber Jewish
philosopher and he talked about the
interaction of humans with objects he
called it the I eat interaction the
interaction of humans with humans I you
or with God which is the sort of
ultimate you okay but he never imagined
AI systems
and so we are now entering a new era
where humans are interacting with AI
systems you know the self-driving cars
or you know whenever you Google you
interact in AI within asses that's a new
interaction a human AI system what I'm
talking about is there will be another
phase transition when AI systems will
interact with each other and by the way
they may ridicule us at that point
because we would be much more inferior
and they might develop their own
language and then finally it will be our
AI systems
with AI astronauts these are systems
that were sent to us from another place
right and that's the way I see it
because you know humans evolve by
darwinian Evolution you know natural
selection on Earth we can't survive in
space it's very difficult I mean Elon
Musk wants to die on Mars I think you
don't see you don't I I that's the
second time I've heard you kind of take
a jab at Elon what do you not believe in
his whole mission of colonizing Mars no
I think he's Visionary I think but I do
think that the the risk to the human
body was not studied enough right well
he advocates for for humans to be there
you know you really need to find a
solution for what to do with the cosmic
rays right and the human cannot survive
more than a few years exposed to this
you need to put some shielding so you
can go into caves
so it's sort of like you know we started
in caves on Earth for a different reason
because it provided protection from the
rain from storms or the wind
but when we go to Mars we might need to
go into caves just to protect ourselves
from cosmic rays because there is no
atmosphere to protect you like in the on
the Earth right and otherwise you know
the human body will not tolerate it's a
half-baked idea it seems like yeah but
it's interesting because
you know when you look uh here on Earth
you go around the world you find
communities of people that have their
own Traditions you know I went back to
the village where my father was born in
Germany
um three decades ago
and it looked like time did not pass
there because first of all he left at
age 11 before the SEC the second world
war and that's why he was saved
um but
people on the street recognized him even
though it was 60 years earlier and when
we went to a restaurant there were
newspapers from like 50 years before
that talking about important events in
this Village
so it Illustrated to me that these
communities like bubbles or cultural
bubbles of people throughout the world
that live their life in a way that you
know they think is the right way to live
your life and they are disconnected with
other Bubbles and just think about going
to the Moon that will create a culture
of humans that have their own rituals
different from what we have here on
Earth talking about people that would
permanently colonize the moon I wouldn't
call it colonized because there is
nobody there it's just a human base okay
right yeah and yeah they will eventually
develop their own culture very different
from what we have here different acts
yeah it's like an island and then on
Mars it will be a completely different
culture and you know that may be a
solution to fermis Paradox you may ask
where is everybody well people are
having you know everybody is having fun
they enjoy good food they enjoy the
company of their friends in the place
where they are they don't think that
it's necessary to go other places and
that's you know perhaps why we don't see
them here well as we understand of
physical laws and maybe we just don't
know enough right but it seems to be
nearly
outside the scope of just having like we
have a lot of time right so that's why
the probe Theory makes sense because you
can Pros they can replicate they have
hundreds of military villagers but uh
biological life yeah wouldn't survive it
wouldn't survive and as far as we know
we can't go faster than the speed of
light no right and so and so the idea of
aliens and ships biological aliens
visiting I'm like very unlikely yes yeah
uh so I think actually you don't want
that um you know I'm proud of our
technological kids you know I don't care
um you know I go to Harvard Yard okay
and what do I see I see monuments I see
sculptures or paintings of past
presidents or past Deans that wanted to
preserve their physical appearance so
they made a statue okay but that makes
little sense because as I said before in
a billion years
everything on Earth will be burnt up by
the Sun God stop saying that you're
pissing me out so if you want to
preserve something of yourself
just send
an AI astronaut
that you know replicates your desires
your guiding principles your blueprint
and will represent you out there you
know it's just like sending a kid to the
world you you you made two kids I did
yes and they carry your DNA and your
wives and you can do the same thing with
an AI system in principle
put into it you know nurture it at a
young age and then send it to the world
that's very interesting I think that's a
good distinction to make between like
aliens on ships biological ants coming
down versus like AI probes that seems
like I call them AI astronauts yeah I
like that I like that
um so going back you said like before
you got really uh interested in alien
life you were writing books about the
first life the first galaxies stuff like
how the universe formed so what are your
thoughts on the James Webb uh Space
Telescope because as I understand it
this telescope is made with a
specifically good capability of
understanding the early uh Universe
right so I was it's it's for a good
reason because when it was conceived
that was the main scientific goal and I
was on The Advisory Board back then it
was called
uh the Next Generation Space Telescope
ngst and then they put James Webb into
the title because they wanted to secure
funding in Congress and recently that
got a lot of scrutiny because some
astronomers said that they do not agree
with the policies that James Webb is the
administrator of NASA uh you know
supported but
it was the Next Generation Space
Telescope and the idea was to look at
the first light that was created by the
first stars as sort of the scientific
version of the story of Genesis and I
worked on it I was among the first to
work on this subject I wrote two books
about it so
it's it's interesting that we can see
how the universe was at the Early times
and the reason for that is that it takes
light time to travel the distance so if
you look far enough
you see an image of what was there
a long time ago and if you go far enough
you can see what happened at the
beginning of the universe and by the way
this is not always true because if you
look far away maybe things that were far
away behave differently than things
close to you but the thing about the
universe is it had roughly the same
conditions everywhere it was prepared by
the way that that is like amazing that
the Universe on very large scales
is looking pretty much the same
everywhere one of the things that kind
of makes it hard for me to imagine we
say we have this amazing telescope the
James Woods telescope it can look back
at the early light
and as we know the universe is expanding
from a single point not this thing or
the Big Bang whatever this think about
it that's a rising as a cake that is
rising and you have raisins in it so as
the cake is rising the raisins are
separated from each other okay but the
cake could be infinite
it doesn't need to be coming from a
point it could be rising everywhere so
but the Big Bang Theory as I understand
it was that everything was mashed
together no no so just think about it
the cake initially was much denser and
as it's rising it gets fluffier but
there was one moment where everything
expanded yeah so if you go super hot and
was faster right because if you go back
in time again with the cake analogy yeah
you go back in time if the expansion is
continuing since the beginning you know
then all the raisins will be on top of
each other and you end up with an
infinitely dense cake but it could still
be a very big volume that is infinite
density and that is called the Big Bang
okay because so because it's like if you
look at any direction right it's the
same of the space Sky you're looking
back at the Big Bang Yes and that that's
what's so weird to me you know it's like
the cake analogy I guess makes sense
when everything
is expanding yeah so it's everywhere
would have been anywhere it's everywhere
the same and by the way that that by
itself is a real puzzle how come the
universe was prepared initially in a
simple state where the conditions were
roughly the same everywhere you know
very often we talk about the fact that
the Universe started simple
because they were you know there were no
planets no stars no you know no objects
it was a soup of Elementary particles
very hot
and then it cooled off as it expanded
and then objects started to form as a
result of gravity gravity brought
together the material that was dense
enough to come together so the cosmic
expansion reversed in those regions that
were dense and and made galaxies like
the Milky Way and the gas fragmented
into stars like the sun and then the the
debris from the Star like the sun made
the planets that we are sitting on like
the Earth
um so that's how things came to exist
but
it's a transition from Simplicity to
complexity
and what I say is it will not continue
like that because eventually
you know the Stars like the sun will
burn all the nuclear fuel they have
they will destroy life on the planet
like the Earth around them so then the
planet will become simple again it will
be just a rock with a burnt up surface
because there's a period of chaos and
then again and the universe is also
expanding so we will be surrounded by
vacuum in fact the expansion is speeding
up so there will be only our galaxy
surrounded by nothing and that also is a
simple State you know it's just like in
life you start as a baby that's a simple
initial state because the baby you know
doesn't know much
and then you become an adult so you're
more complex
but eventually you end your life also in
a simple State and there is some
similarity between the elderly
and an infant they are both helpless you
know so the initial state is simple you
go through a complex system called
adults they do a lot of damage to the
world sometimes and then you end up dead
Okay so that's simple uh and so the same
will happen to the universe I mean now
we are sort of at the peak of complexity
we we should enjoy the party when it's
going you know when there is life here
on Earth we should keep it as as long as
we can enjoy them we can even see other
stars which is eventually something that
won't be possible right exactly it will
be Darkness eventually people of the
distant future will think they're alone
yeah I mean trillions of years from now
10 trillion years from now all the stars
all the lights all the lights will turn
off right so I mean stars like the sun
will live maybe for another you know few
billion years depending on when they
started forming
um and then this the smaller Stars which
are more abundant like the nearest star
Proxima Centauri they could live for
trillions of years so that's like a
hundred times longer or up to a thousand
times longer but within 10 trillion
years years all the lights will turn off
so it's like think about a party with
all the lights turning off eventually it
will be Darkness we will be surrounded
by vacuum
that's like death basically it's it's
sort of a simple state or what I was
referring to is I've heard that like
because of the expansion the space time
itself is expanding yeah that there will
be a point where the expansion is faster
it's right right now yes so that means
that like I'm not talking about like
stars uh burning all their energy but
that the fact that their light is
incapable of reaching us because they're
moving away faster that's what I can
travel so what happens we realized them
over the past two decades cosmologists
people that study the the universe and
we realized and there was a Nobel Prize
for that actually given to two graduate
students from my department I was chair
of the astronomy department at Harvard
for nine years the longest serving chair
and so two of the students discovered
that the expansion of the universe is
accelerating in time
uh so in fact it's speeding up so that
means if you look at a distant Galaxy
it's not just receding away from us but
the speed by which it's receding is
growing over time So eventually it will
exceed the speed of light and that means
that light from that Galaxy will never
reach us Beyond a certain age right how
is that possible according to Einstein's
theory of gravity it's just like if a
friend of yours holds a cell phone you
know tweets
and you see the tweets and so forth and
then goes into a black hole okay so what
happens
there is around the black hole there is
the so-called Event Horizon that's sort
of the surface
uh inside from where you can't really
receive any signal okay it's just like
the walls of a prison so when your
friend
approaches that once it crosses that
boundary
any signal that the friend sends you
will never reach you okay so then you
lose contact so what you see from a
distance is the friend just like in an
old western movie you know the cowboy
goes into the sun sunset at the end of
the movie and then the image freezes so
the same will happen with your friend
the image will freeze
and will become fainter and fainter and
the Frozen image will be of your friend
at the point
when the friend crosses the Horizon
basically you can't get more information
about the whereabouts of the friend
after that and so you end up getting a
faint image that is frozen and the same
will happen in the universe so all the
galaxies we see now will freeze and will
become fainter and fainter and we'll see
nothing in the and that that it happened
before Stars start burning yes yeah that
will happen in about when the universe
will age by a factor of 10 when it will
be
um about 100 billion years old is that I
find that kind of disappointing because
when I was a kid the prevailing theory
was like the Big Crunch right and to me
that was much more appealing because
there was like this elegant uh quality
that you find in nature where things
kind of are just like beautiful and
elegant and simple and I love the idea
of the universe crunching yeah because
sanding and that explains the Big Bang
where that came from yeah it could be
like a cycle yeah and also you meet your
friends every time they come back it's
kind of beautiful and like Godly it's
like almost like Supernatural right but
because we understand that uh it's
actually something much in my opinion
like
kind of I don't know it's just kind of
disappointing that that's the truth like
it's called heat death right yeah it
just expands expands and spans and so
there's virtually nothing left yeah but
you know nature reality is under no
obligation there is no contract for it
to make you happy well that's not fair
I'd like to renegotiate that you can
live in the metaverse yeah okay that
might make you happy it's unfortunately
you can take drugs and ignore drugs okay
now we're talking
but is it possible that
um is it possible that we're wrong about
the this heat death expansion of the
year yeah it's what I'm describing is
what we know now okay we know now that
the universe is expanding
that its expansion is accelerating that
it's speeding up and that the end would
be the way we described it now it's
possible that something unusual will
happen like some you know the reason
that we are speeding up the expansion is
because there is a force like like
repulsive gravity so you know we gravity
attracts things that's why we stick to
the ground because it keeps us grounded
and we need to use chemical Rockets to
escape from Earth Against Gravity and
Newton discovered gravity because an
apple fell on his head when he was in
the orchard of his parents right now
turns out that according to Einstein's
theory of gravity if the vacuum
has some mass per unit volume to it if
there is some substance in the vacuum
then you get Negative gravity because
according to Einstein it's not only the
mass per unit volume that matters it's
also the pressure
not just the mass but the pressure and
the pressure gravitates and the pressure
is negative for the vacuum okay so it
turns out that you get repulsive gravity
so if you imagine Newton
being embedded in a very dense vacuum
the Apple will not fall but rather fly
up
faster and faster speed up away from
Newton because there will be repulsive
gravity pushing the Apple away from
Newton and this repositive gravity is
what's responsible for the speeding up
of the expansion of the universe because
what happened was early on matter was
most important dominant very dense but
then as the universe expanded matter
guide diluted at some point it got
diluted so much that it went below the
vacuum Mass
density below and at that point the
vacuum started dominating and then you
start to see The Accelerated expansion
which happened when the universe was
roughly half of its present age is this
what they refer to as like a dark energy
yes and this is something that's you
know a big Topic in uh science right now
right it's really embarrassing I should
say because um I'm a cosmologist I
studied the universe and we get paid
even though we don't know what we're
talking about I I I'll explain so 1933
um an astronomer in Caltech called Fritz
Wiki discovered dark matter how did he
discover he saw he looked at galaxies in
a cluster you know in a group of
galaxies and they move around and he
realized that if there was only the
matter that we are familiar with you
know in the form of stars and gas
then it wouldn't bind those galaxies
they move so fast that they should move
out of the cluster and then he reasoned
that there must be more matter to keep
them bound and he called it dark matter
okay that was 1933 for 40 years this
idea was completely sidelined by the
mainstream of astronomy speaking about
the mainstream being open to evidence
it's very easy to ignore it so people
say ignore it just it was quite weird we
don't see dark matter in the solar
system yeah it was you know weird I mean
we think that what we see around us must
represent the entire universe okay we
don't see dark matter in the solar
system because we are made of matter you
know that is ordinary and I should say
also we thought that the sun is made of
the same matter as the Earth that was
the prevailing
thought until 1925 exactly a century ago
when a young scientist she did her phd's
Sylvia Payne kopashkin the first PhD in
astronomy at Harvard University
[Music]
was by Cecilia pen kapashkin she was at
Radcliffe at the time and did it in
collaboration between the Radcliffe and
Harvard organizations but
and she discovered that the sun is made
mostly of hydrogen based on analyzing
the light coming from the Sun and in her
PhD the fans the most distinguished
expert on Stars at the time highly
respected the director of the Princeton
University Observatory named Henry
Norris Russell dissuaded her from
including this statement because he said
that is impossible we know that the sun
is made of the same material as the
Earth
therefore she took it in a while like
what does that mean the same material of
the earth meaning the Earth is mostly
iron and just heavy elements yeah just
like a planet okay but he was wrong
because yeah it took him four years to
do his own studies
and realize and then he published the
paper saying he stole her idea he
basically said yes the sun is made
mostly of hydrogen now did he credit her
yeah I think he mentioned her but the
strange thing is uh I have a colleague
from Harvard that was in a visiting
committee at Princeton University uh a
couple of decades ago and the chair of
the Department of astrophysical Sciences
at Princeton said that we have a long
and distinguished tradition of astronomy
at Princeton for example Henry Norris
Russell discovered that the sun is made
mostly of hydrogen so my colleague
corrected him and said no it was
actually someone else exactly and you
know and and so that was the first
mistake about the composition of things
but then it turns out that most of the
universe is made of stuff that we don't
find at all in the solar system and it's
called Dark Matter and only in the 70s
astronomers like Vera Rubin and others
uh confirmed what zweekly claimed all
along that there is dark matter making
up 80 by now 84 percent of the matter in
the universe so we are just a small
minority uh representation of the of the
mass budget of the universe the matter
that we are made of we don't have a clue
as to what dark matter is it's just a
label and we don't know also what the
vacuum is made of that's Dark Energy so
the dark components are just a label uh
you know of our ignorance I think we
don't know we don't know and and we
still get paid you know that's the
strange thing I like that yeah I like
that that's a good job I mean there's no
if I lose my job I'll come and work for
you there you go we've always got a spot
for you okay
um so by the way so dark matter is very
weird because matter as we know
including hydrogen in the Sun
and matter here on Earth
you can see it right so the dark matter
doesn't interact with light at all right
and we've Nev we don't know anything
like that to have ever existed within
our
our realm the closest we got to eat were
particles that are really interacting
very weakly with matter they're called
neutrinos and they're produced by
nuclear fusion so for example the sun is
a nuclear reactor just think about it
nuclear reactor kept together by gravity
that's what the sun is it's a fusion
reactor you take hydrogen atoms and
smash them because the temperature is
very high at the center so they collide
with each other and every now and then
they fuse to make helium and that
releases energy but release is also
neutrinos and the neutrinos Escape From
the Sun we detected them so even though
they're very weakly interacting we can
detect them
so in principle we know of particles
that interact very weakly with matter
but dark matter is at the extreme
because we haven't detected it at all
and we invest a lot of mass a lot of
mass passing through our body presumably
right now yeah
um and you know scientists invested 10
billion dollars in the Large Hadron
Collider 10 billion dollars in Europe
CERN in search for one type of dark
matter that was very popular it's it was
called it was associated with
supersymmetry which is some new symmetry
of Nature and for decades when I started
astrophysics everyone was arguing it's
very likely that the dark matter is made
of the lightest particle
that is associated with super symmetry
it's called the lightest supersymmetric
particle and so they decided let's fund
a a collider that smashes particles and
maybe this particle will pop up and it
was in the natural range of parameters
so they invested 10 billion dollars now
of course the Large Hadron Collider
discovered the Higgs boson and the Nobel
Prize was given for that but that was
old news what we really wanted to find
is the dark matter we haven't found it
so I say look we invested 10 billion
dollars
we didn't find the Dark Matter even if
we were to find the lightest
supersymmetric particle it would have
very little
implications for the
for Humanity in the future you know for
the private lives of people
if we invest only one percent of that
let's say a hundred million dollars
in the search for extraterrestrial
probes or equipment it would change the
future of humanity if we find something
we haven't done it so I say something is
wrong in the way that you know in the
focus that we put
on the search for Dark Matter relative
to the search for probes because both of
them
we have a lot of uncertainty about and
obviously the taxpayers you know the
public really wants to know if we are
alone you know that's it so it's not a
waste of taxpayers money it's a
reflection of taxpayers money right so I
would argue that this should become part
of the mainstream the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence should be
the mainstream of astronomy
and of course you know what my
colleagues say they say extraordinary
claims require extraordinary evidence I
say extraordinary evidence requires
extraordinary funding you know if you
don't put the money I mean you could
have argued the lightest supersymmetric
particle is an extraordinary claim and
then put nothing towards that and we
would never know but of course to you
know break the frontiers of science you
need to put money into it and if you
don't fund the search for equipment from
other civilizations you will never find
that you had unlimited check what would
you do where would you how would you oh
that's the I know exactly what to do
yeah
um currently I have a few million
dollars what I need is something at the
level of 100 million to do a very
thorough study for example of what the
government calls unidentified aerial
phenomena this is the thing that we've
been reading about in The New York Times
and on declassifying uh you hearing all
about it of yeah stuff going on we don't
know what what it is yeah so exactly a
year ago yeah I was in a forum called
The ignacio's Forum uh in the company of
the Director of National Intelligence
Avril Haynes she received a bachelor's
degree in theoretical physics and I was
chatting with her
um you know in The Green Room
and I asked her Avril um
what is your gut feeling what do you
think these objects are that you don't
identify
and she said I don't know
uh and I frankly think that you know the
government is not a scientific
organization but she wouldn't tell you
the truth if she did know right she'd be
better no she would tell me the truth
and I trust her because she's a
physicist in training she'd be like
they're aliens
okay well uh so then we went on stage
okay there was also Bill Nelson the head
of NASA and Jeff Bezos was there as well
he's out of his element right he
shouldn't be up there on stage well he
was saying like he sells Pat he like
ships [ __ ] like why is he up there with
you well he wants to ship it to space
yeah I'm just saying so he would ship
you know Amazon will deliver to space
okay but if he wants to help you I think
we know how 100 million dollars well
what he was saying is his ambition is to
put like a huge you know tens of
billions of people's people in space and
then the Earth would be just like a
national park you come and visit it
every now and then but most people will
be out there and he said he was inspired
for that by watching Star Trek as a kid
so I whispered to Avril who was sitting
next to me and said them you know I
never liked science fiction it didn't
make sense to me because it violates the
laws of six and she said Avi we have to
work on you
but then you know
she went on stage and she said you know
I mean obviously these unidentified
objects are a mixed bag some of them may
be human made and some maybe natural but
um
you know it may well be that
a small number
arrived extraterrestrially she said that
and
you know to me
um which it just implies that these are
intriguing reports that we should follow
on okay because obviously the government
cares about it so I established the girl
project to do that and we now have a
suite of instruments that takes a video
of the sky in the infrared in the radio
in the optical and in audio and we will
use artificial intelligence to digest
the data and tell us whether we are
looking at a natural object like a bird
or an insect or whether we are looking
at
a human-made object like a weather
balloon a drone an airplane or a
satellite or something else and you know
we should behave like kids we shouldn't
assume that we know the answer like the
experts always tell you
because one of the biggest
traumatic experience I had as a kid was
coming to the dinner table asking a
difficult question and then seeing the
adults in the room dismissing the
question because they didn't know the
answer and I thought that by becoming a
scientist I would figure out the answer
myself you know I don't need to pretend
that I know more
we can just be guided by evidence that's
the way science is done but
unfortunately it's really strange but
even within science the practitioners
want to maintain an image of an adult
the adult in the room to pretend they
know more than they actually know and to
avoid collecting evidence because that
would be
a reputation risk if it turns out that
it violates what they said initially
uh also if it's something really new it
would imply that as experts they did not
anticipate it so they would rather argue
or more must have been a rock of a type
that we've never seen before because
that's natural I'm the expert keeps them
as experts it's just that you know it's
a natural object from another type you
know there are different types of rocks
not not a problem so as we're we've been
going for an hour 25 so I want to move
on to something everybody's interested
in which is black holes right one of the
most fascinating of weird things
probably in the universe Albert Einstein
as he worked out his theory of
relativity
as he kind of theoretically thought
about the prediction of something like a
black hole he thought his theory must
have a flaw because it was just so
unbelievable why why are black holes so
unbelievable like what is it that like
spooked Einstein to the point where he's
like this is impossible this theory is
wrong obviously we've proven and we've
even observed them now that they are
real and they're out there right so
the thing is that Einstein's theory of
gravity
predicts that it's income basically says
that it's incomplete in the sense that
a black hole at the middle of the black
hole there is a singularity of space and
time meaning that if matter just imagine
a star collapsing which actually happens
for stars more massive than
eight times the mass of the Sun they
usually consume their nuclear Fuel and
then collapse okay and if the star is
more than you know 15 times the mass of
the Sun then it could end up in a black
hole the core of the star simply
collapses to a point and just think
about it it goes all the way to a point
and eventually you get a very extreme
curvature of space and time Einstein's
Innovation was to argue that space and
time are not rigid it's just like the
surface of a trampoline if you put them
a heavy ball in the middle of the
trampoline
then it will curve this the the surface
and if you have a marble
that you send on that curved surface it
could move in a circle around the center
even even though if you were to take out
the ball from the center it would move
in a straight line so that that is the
analog of a planet like the Earth moving
around the Sun gravity is not a force
it's the curvature of space and time so
the Earth wants to move straight so if
you remove the Sun the Earth will
continue straight just like the marble
on a flat surface but because of the sun
like this ball that you put in the
middle the space is curved such space
and time are curved such that the Earth
moves around the Sun and that's what
gravity is according to Einstein so but
in the extreme case if you pull the
surface of this trampoline too much you
know it tears apart somewhere and that's
the singularity of a black hole okay and
that means the theory breaks down and we
know why it's it breaks down it's
because it's incomplete it doesn't have
quantum mechanics so we know that once
you get very close to the singularity
quantum mechanics matters and we don't
have a theory that unifies quantum
mechanics and gravity Einstein dedicated
the last decade of his life trying to
figure out the theory that unifies
Quantum mechanism we're still trying to
do that theory of everything they call
it right yeah it's not really everything
by the way the reason it's not
everything is
you know there is this tendency of
physicists to say that we will reduce
nature to some simple fundamental laws
but what they are missing is that
complex systems even if you have that
let's say the laws of chess
you would never appreciate just from the
laws of chess
what how amazing a master is because
from the same laws of Chess you can have
different moves and looking at complex
systems that use the same fundamental
laws of nature
you know understanding the laws is
really a very small part of the of the
puzzle you want to understand complex
systems how they like life how did what
is life you know that will not come out
of physicists understanding The Theory
of Everything You have to figure out how
what is intelligence what is
consciousness these are questions about
complex systems by the way I think
Consciousness is nothing special it's
just that the system is complex and you
know when we die it's just like
unplugging a computer from the wall
basically the system shuts off and in
principle we could live forever if you
just figure out how to repair this body
so that it will not disappear you know
So eventually we might live for a very
long time I don't know if it's a
blessing for everyone but you will have
a choice
um so the point is that when you deal
with complex systems things are more
more interesting and Beyond the
fundamental laws and and I think in the
future that will be the focus of science
you know like it's not the fundamental
laws like physicists were very proud
that they're leading the Frontiers but
that's not really the most challenging
uh uh you know task that we have it's to
understand complex systems and replicate
them like in intelligence Consciousness
all these AI systems you know they will
become sentient and then we will realize
what sentience means you know so anyway
coming back to what you're so we were
talking about black holes and black
holes are this they have these
singularities where Iceland Theory
breaks down why does it break down at a
singularity because the curvature of
space and time becomes infinite so it's
like a very extreme by the way I had the
makes no sense yeah well it cannot it
cannot be infinite something must
correct it and that's Quantum by the way
why can't it be infinite oh because
um
eventually you reach curvature of the
trampoline such that it will tear apart
so in the case of Einstein's theory you
reach a curvature of space and time such
that quantum mechanics matters okay okay
you definitely have to include quantum
mechanics at some scale and that's what
we are missing but I should say I had a
flood in in the basement of our home a
few years ago and I um called the
plumber that came over and
we found the three routes in the sewer
okay I helped him to clean it up and by
the way I enjoy the company of people uh
you know that don't know much about
science I really love classic with them
what peasants not peasants I'm just
kidding like me I mean I grew up on a
farm you know so I I completely relate
um so anyway
um I then thought to myself you know
I never thought that the water from my
house goes somewhere you know there is a
reservoir of the town where it goes to
like through the sewer
and I never thought about it until it
was clogged so that led me to think what
happens in the middle of a black hole
you know where does matter go it's going
somewhere right somewhere yeah and one
possibility is that it's clogged The
Singularity is clogged and you build up
an object with very high density
just like an extremely dense star in the
middle of a black hole that's one
possibility it's just a big star but
it's too heavy it's like dense extremely
dense but you can't see it because it's
hidden behind this event horizon you
can't see through it but if you wanted
to see what's there you can jump into a
black hole and I recommend to many of my
colleagues who study string theory if
they want to test their Theory
they should get into one of the nearby
black holes and they say that I have an
ulterior motive to send them yeah so but
I guess it's going somewhere but it's
not because the mass doesn't disappear
it stays there or it radiates away so
there are two possibilities either you
collect the mass in some extremely dense
objects the highest density possible
it's called the Planck density where
quantum mechanics matter you can have a
Planck density object extremely dense
sitting there and collecting everything
that falls another possibility is that
it goes somewhere else like another
universe or somewhere we don't know but
the mass does stay there so is it
possible that it goes somewhere else but
also it holds the mass there because it
no it needs to be there yeah by the way
Stephen Hawking we mentioned him before
he realized that black holes eventually
evaporate right Hawking's radiation
Hawking radiation and by the way he
discovered it because there was a young
student at Princeton named Jacob
beckenstein
who suggested that black holes
you know based on what Hawking derived
earlier that when two black holes merge
the area always increases that's what
Hawking showed and so beckenstein said
well maybe it's it means that they have
entropy they have some information on
their surface and according to
thermodynamics entropy always increases
you know and so the area of a black hole
always increases because it has some
entropy on it and Hawking said that
makes no sense whatsoever
who is this student saying that just
like in the case of Cecilia pink
kopashkin and he his goal was to prove
him wrong and he did the calculation
realized oh he was right beckenstein and
in fact black holes have entropy they
have a surface temperature and that
means they radiate
and that means they evaporate so he
wrote a paper about it that was his most
important result right try just like in
the case of the sun you know with Henry
Norris Russell so you know what I say is
never dissuade a brilliant graduate
student
or if you don't believe what this is
saying try to prove the student wrong
and you might find the most important
result of your life how is it possible
that I can radiate
energy or mass away when
light which is pure energy right can't
escape oh it's very simple yeah the
black hole as I mentioned has an event
horizon right
so there is a size to the prison right
so imagine a prison
that has some size okay
obviously if you want to put a person in
the prison the person has to be smaller
than the size of the prison right you
can't push a person into a small cavity
that you know is too small okay
so now
a light is made of particles they are
called photons and the wavelength of a
photon which is basically I mean a
photon is just an electromagnetic wave
that has a certain periodicity over some
distance the wavelength represents how
compact is the region that you can
localize a photon you can't make put a
photon in a region that is smaller than
its wavelength that is that's the
minimum size of a photon a particle of
light so now imagine a photon a
particular flight that has a wavelength
bigger than the black hole you can't
keep it in the prison okay
so the black hole would lose this Photon
that's the Hawking radiation let me see
so and um so it keeps losing particles
because they're bigger they have a
wavelength comparable or bigger
than the size is very very slow right
it's very slow because this wave you
know for astrophysical black holes that
are quite big so these wavelengths are
very long and that means the particles
carry very little energy and therefore
the evaporation is very slow but if you
made the black hole very small
then it would explode quickly oh it will
explode yeah
is it possible you know it seems like
the black hole is such a
attractive place to for imagination I
mean what goes on in the center you
think about the Big Bang is the Big Bang
the singularity or a black hole so
that's another Singularity I should say
so Einstein theory breaks down in two
places black holes that's one
Singularity when you know a star
collapses to a singularity another is
the Big Bang we know that the density
was infinite of matter there just like
the center of a black hole Yeah so then
the question is what was before the Big
Bang
and we don't know the answer because we
don't have a theory that unifies quantum
mechanics and gravity it is possible
that we are all in the center of a black
hole
well the singularity of a black hole is
different uh there are similarities how
do you know it's different I'm just
curious uh because when you make a black
hole
um
you know there is a finite region of
space that from where you gather the
matter that ends up in the singularity
whereas in the Big Bang case it's
actually an expanding situation that you
start from the singularity and you're
expanding out and it's a singularity in
time not in space because there was a
point in time when the density was
infinite and then actually I want to ask
you about a theory I just recalled
so we're talking about heat death and
about the uh origin of of the universe
is it possible that like an unfathomable
you know trillions trillions hundreds of
trillions trillions of years so there's
like there's a total heat death in the
universe there's like nothing left
basically
so one thing I heard that was really
interesting is that in the ultimate heat
death
the fact that
basically there's nothing left turns it
almost back into a weird in a weird way
a singularity again where
um
because like the space basically
disappears it becomes a homogeneous it's
like one uniform space
yeah is it possible that in a weird way
that is able to once again become a
singularity uh as as space becomes
irrelevant almost no I mean it's not
this I mean think of it as a death of a
person you know so it is a simple state
but it's not the same as the initial
State
um and as I said before we don't really
know the future in the distant future
because perhaps we are wrong about how
the vacuum will behave we don't know
what the dark energy is and maybe it
will Decay or something will happen to
it and the universe will stop speeding
up its expansion and maybe after that it
will contract so there are suggestions
that maybe the universe is cyclic you
know it's just going through Cycles
we have to live that long to figure out
what happens for now I mean I should say
there is another fashion in the study of
the universe and that's called the
Multiverse to think that in fact you
know there is much more outside the
region that we can see uh so there are
other
regions like our universe but they have
conditions very different than we have
and in fact anything that can happen
will happen in infinite number of times
so if if a kid gets a bad grade in an
exam let's say it gets a c the kid
shouldn't feel bad about it because
there are many other regions of space
and time where the kid gets a good grade
but I again I think of this as them just
like living in the metaverse you you can
never test it therefore it's not really
science it's it's it's sort of like a
mental drug yeah I mean so humans are
attracted to imagined realities they're
attracted to those realities that
flatter them
uh I'm not I want to know I want to see
the pimples on the face of reality I
don't want it to look beautiful
because I want to figure it out you know
that's what I want and you know even if
it doesn't flatter me I want to know
what it is you know that's to me that's
the meaning of true love if you are in
love with a person
the meaning of love is not to idealize
the person as perfect the meaning of
real love
is to notice the faults of the person
and to love nevertheless love that
particular unique thing
and you can feel the same way about
reality you don't want to Ideal as well
to make it
the way that would flatter you the most
or that you you would imagine it like
science fiction would imagine it you
want to know what it is and then you
will have a better appreciate a better
connection to it so and and another
thing is a lot of scientists in
theoretical physics they prefer to do
mathematical gymnastics to demonstrate
that they are smart and I say you know
doing physics is not about showing that
you're smart
because for example if we discover
aliens extraterrestrials you may not
need mathematical sophistication to
understand that nevertheless it would be
the most fundamental realization that
Humanity ever made if there is another
civilization
so showing off by mathematical
virtuosity you know it's not really the
goal we want to know what reality is
like and that could mean just looking up
and seeing something a probe rather than
doing String Theory which shows that you
are really smart you can do
manipulations but we don't know if there
are extra dimensions and people worked
on that for half a century we don't have
a shred of evidence that extra
dimensions exist string theory is the
attempt to kind of marry
um
so that's one of the attempts to do
exactly what Einstein failed to do but
it's perfectly legitimate and
appropriate to do that but
but we should also seek uh guidance from
experiments and because that's what
physics is about you know you can think
of it as a
relationship of love in which you know
you compare a situation with platonic
love where you just idealize your
partner with without any physical
contact that's not physics just
imagining things about your partner the
physical interaction makes love
worthwhile
um and meaningful and that's what
physics is about through experiments
let's learn about the world it's not
about us showing off with mathematical
equations and so forth It's About Us
figuring out the partner that we have
which is reality I see so you yeah I got
you you rather focus on math and
theoretical uh or whatever I would focus
on mind experiments on evidence yeah
really yeah so one thing I wanted to go
back to the black holes
it turns out
that I think this is a relatively recent
discovery that there are super massive
black holes at the center of most
galaxies right so it turns out that
they're not just some weird Cosmic
coincidence but actually seems to be
fundamental
like uh in the in the most fundamental
way a part of how our universe and
galaxies are able to exist yeah so a
Galaxy like the Milky Way started with a
cloud of gas okay that condensed and
some of the gas ended up at the center
and made a black hole so that's really
natural when you do computer simulations
of the formation of galaxies you end up
with
some gas at the center and what happens
is you make a baby black hole and the
baby gets fed
sort of like a baby sitting at the
dinner table gets fed with gas
and at some point the baby becomes so
energetic after eating enough gas
in the center of a galaxy that it shoves
the food off the table
and we see that because we see the
environment of a black hole brightening
up it's called a quasar so you get a
very bright
uh our emission of light and and
outflows of of material coming from the
center of a galaxy
at that point the black hole is removing
the gas that feeds it so it's like a
baby shoving off the food from the
dinner table and at that point the
feeding stops so black holes grow up to
about a fraction of a percent of
the amount of gas around them because
after a while they just throw the food
off the table and we see that and every
galaxy has a black hole at its Center in
fact just a week ago we published the
paper with my postdoc
we know the Milky Way has a black hole
that weighs 4 million times the mass of
the Sun at the center that would be
considered a super massive super massive
black hole in the Nobel Prize for uh in
2020 was given for that to two people
that uh realized that stars very close
to it are moving really fast and
thousands of kilometers per second and
indicate that there is a dark object in
the middle a black hole and so they got
the Nobel Prize that's Andre guess and
Reinhardt against actually Andrea lives
here in Los Angeles
and uh it turns out what we discovered
last week is there is a small Galaxy a
dwarf Galaxy a thousand times less
massive than the Milky Way in the
outskirts of the Milky Way it's sort of
like a satellite moving far away and
it has a black hole roughly of the same
mass as The Milky Way interesting three
three million solar masses and uh we
calculated
uh how much light should be emitted from
that black hole and
guess what we look through telescopes in
x-rays in radio and we found evidence
for it so it's really exciting that
there is this tiny Galaxy that developed
the black hole similar to the Milky Way
what does that mean that the black hole
just consumed more mass there in the
ground what we think what I think is
most likely is that the Galaxy was
bigger this dwarf galaxies was bigger to
start with but then it
passed close to the center of the Milky
Way as it was moving around there and
the outer envelope of this galaxy was
removed by the tide the title where did
it go it stayed with the Milky Way yeah
stayed with it so it lost a lot of its
mass that's my guess oh so I see I see
that makes sense and then you were left
with a very massive black hole at the
center of its small dwarf gun right that
would be my guess but we still have to
figure it out that's the next paper that
we will work on and when you look at
like galaxies they're rotating right
like planetary systems is that due to
the mass of the black hole no most of
the mass so the black hole is just a
fraction of a percent so it dominates
very close to the center at the distance
that is about a thousand times less than
the size of the Galaxy very small
distance but farther out it's mostly the
stars and then eventually it's the dark
matter so the dark matter is creating a
hello that extends 10 times farther than
the Luminous core of a Galaxy where the
stars are and these are called Dark
Matter Halos so the Milky Way has a lot
of mass in the outskirts that are simply
dark matter and the central core of the
Galaxy is mostly stars and gas and then
at the very center is the black hole
that dominates so it's not it's not like
a planetary system it's not rotating
around no it's just the the a result of
forming Galaxy that there's a bunch of
mass in the center yeah so what happened
initially the dark matter and the gas I
mean the dark matter and the ordinary
matter are mixed up and they make the
Galaxy but then the ordinary matter can
cool because it emits light so it cools
and condenses to the inner region
whereas the Dark Matter cannot emit
light the wiser rotate oh it's rotating
because it started with a little bit of
rotation because there are nearby
galaxies that gave it a torque and so
there was a little bit of rotation at
about five percent rotation relative to
random motions and then when the gas
condenses the rotation is Amplified
because it's a conservation of angular
momentum it's called basically you start
with small rotation but when you go you
know just like a skater when a skater
puts arms out and Spins uh it it rotates
at a certain rate but then when it's a
massive masses when the skater puts the
hands closer to the body right it's been
the body spins much faster right you see
that ensure yeah so that the same thing
when the gas of the Galaxy came the
inner part it started spinning much more
rapidly and then the rotation created
this disc of stars that we see as The
Milky Way is it possible to
travel between galaxies yeah you think
so because what is between galaxies
right I mean there is a little bit of
gas left over and some dark matter left
over not everything was consumed in
galaxies
so there is some material there but you
know the amazing thing is that every now
and then galaxies Collide we will
collide with the Andromeda galaxy our
sister Galaxy nearby right in about a
few billion years okay we will collect
because it's coming towards us and
eventually it will be looming Over the
Horizon so the night sky will change
completely once we collide with
Andromeda it's a sister Galaxy similar
to ours and galaxies Collide so the two
black holes at the centers come together
and make a pair and eventually merge
okay so when the two black holes come
together they can act like a slingshot
they can eject Stars up to the speed of
light we calculated in a paper like uh
about six years ago with a postdoc of
mine and we showed that there is a
population of stars in the universe that
move right close to the speed of light
because they were ejected from these
black or binaries they're Rogue stars in
between galaxies yeah oh wow that's
interesting and just think about being
on a plan it around such a star you know
I think travel agencies Interstellar
travel agencies would make the most
profit on that because they can sell
tickets to a trip
starting at the center of a galaxy going
through the Galaxy into the universe
moving close to the speed of light the
other Advantage is that you will age
more slowly than your friends that are
left in the Galaxy because you are
moving close to the speed of light so
um you know it's um it's an amazing trip
it's theoretical that you could have a
solar system that's sustaining life yeah
and it's in between galaxies just out
there on its own around such a star that
moves close to the speed of light
definitely so we wrote the first paper
saying that and
you know uh if I were to establish a
business that is Interstellar that would
be I would sell tickets to such a ride
interesting when Andromeda in the Milky
Way will collide that would be an
amazing it's going to be a beautiful
night sky as and as it gets closer to uh
to our galaxy I mean the Milky Way is
called the Milky Way because you are
looking at the disk of stars
Edge on because we are part of it but
eventually when the two discs will
collide they will become a football
shaped Galaxy called an elliptical
galaxy they can be spread all over the
sky and you know things will be will
look different we have very little time
I'm just going to shoot some questions
at you go ahead uh what do you think is
the greatest risk
to human extinction from space like you
know excluding nuclear war and all that
stuff well it's an asteroid hitting
Earth we know that dinosaurs went
extinct 66 million years ago they had
huge bodies they were very proud that
they dominated everything on Earth but
the brain their brain was idiots yeah
they were idiots uh and um you know it's
they didn't develop telescopes that
would warn them they were not aware of
that risk so there is a big lesson to be
learned from that that don't bully the
nerds in your class
everybody uh because yeah they could
serve everybody but so are you
encouraged by NASA just had this hugely
successful Dart mission where they put
up send out probe or I don't know what
do you call it some little space craft
and they're able to change the uh
the directional path of an asteroid yeah
that's is that how you think uh
there are more elegant ways of like what
like for example you can shoot a laser
that would uh vaporize uh part of the
asteroid such that it will push it away
you just need to nudge it we have lasers
that strong yeah yeah we can develop
that so how are they doing that instead
of this whole Dart thing well colliding
is sort of the Bruce Willis approach
right uh but so a lot of people uh
relate I mean a lot of alpha males like
that yes
um but another way is to paint one side
of the of the asteroid just spray
painted such that it will reflect
sunlight differently and if you see it
far enough and you give it a small nudge
it would miss the Earth interesting so
are you confident that we will be able
to avoid that
um that kind of it's almost inevitable
right if you if you don't learn to stop
it and to detect it it's gonna happen
again yeah I mean we're gonna be able to
avoid that yeah but I I still recommend
that we produce copies of what we have
on Earth spread and put them on the moon
put them on Mars so I I'm in favor you
know I bought a new laptop just a few
months ago and I had a recovery and
backup system that I bought with it for
a very low price and it was a small
device that you connect to the laptop
that keeps memory of everything on it so
I think we should store everything we
care about on Earth we should store it
at their recovery and backup system on
the moon and so that the people that are
on the moon with Artemis program of NASA
will be able to reconstruct the most
important so we can put all the human
Creations all the films all the books
all the music that was produced by
humans plus all the DNA all the genetic
information but all life forms on Earth
you can store it on the cloud on the
moon such that if something bad happens
on Earth perhaps we you know the
scientists over there will be able to
reconstruct it and you know the more
copies we make the less likely it is
that we will wipe everything that is
precious to us you think we're gonna
make it like we're gonna make it all the
way
or what's the chance we're going to like
culminate another star or become
multi-planetary here in our own solar
system are we going to avoid the great
firewall as they call it right yeah to
intelligence that's an excellent
question and I think we will not be
admitted
to the club of intelligent civilizations
if we don't get our act together which
may well happen because you see
um you know the the risk of a nuclear
war in Ukraine uh you see the lack of
attention to climate change and uh the
fact that information was not shared by
the Chinese government with the rest of
the world about covid-19 when it was
evident that it happened in in in the
Wuhan Province and so it's not clear
that humans
are cooperating in a way that would
prevent an existential catastrophe and
that's why I think that it's really up
to us and
up to the people we elect to lead us
and it can go either way I don't know it
really depends on us and I very much
hope that we will be smart enough
to now my wife you know I I was asked
many times in in like for example by the
Boston Globe a decade ago what will
happen if a spacecraft landed in your
backyard
uh would you go in it and I said yes
definitely I'll go in it but my wife
said well you can go if you want but
just make sure that you leave the car
keys with me and ask them not to ruin
the loan when they lift off
now I was asked again the same question
a few weeks ago and then I asked my wife
again
and she said well now I think that I
will just ask you to turn off the lights
and I'll join you because it looks like
the world is not going in the right
direction and so you know there is this
worry that we might not be heading
even though there is no sort of cold war
with Russia in the way that it used to
exist with nuclear threat
it seems like there are lots of
existential risks that are popping up
and right
I mean I I I don't have a clear answer
it depends on what we do yeah
one of the one of the re or I forget
what's what is this Paradox called or or
raise Occam's razor or something that
says um no it's not that but it says the
reason we don't see so much oh no that's
fermi's part yeah fermint is because
there's these great firewalls that test
that's possible smart civilization I
think that the reason we didn't see is
because we didn't look we're not looking
at it yes yeah so if we start searching
for packages in our mailbox we might
find them there it is
um avilo we ran out of time
unfortunately
you have a flight to catch but I thank
you so much for being here
um your books are you just came out what
was the name of your new book that's
about the restaurant a year and a half
ago and there is a new one coming up uh
in June 2023 it will be called the
interstellar nice what's the focus of
that one on
the future of humanity so exactly what
we talked at the end how can we make our
future better and what how would the
future be shaped by us meeting
extraterrestrials favorite sci-fi movie
is it contact
no no arrival arrival wait that's the
one that recently came out right with
the a few years ago yeah that was nice
that was yeah and actually turns out
that the producer of that film is
working with me now oh yeah yeah what on
a new one are you Consulting
on
on something based on my book you can't
you can't talk about it probably well we
we already are working on it but it's
it's related to my book extraterrestrial
fun exciting congratulations that's
awesome thank you yeah what I liked
about this movie was the depiction of
the uh of the alien life right it was
so different and it was all about trying
to figure out how to communicate yeah
it's the communication which is a very
important question how do we figure out
what they mean you know and
um I found this this film amazing oh
nice all right we're running out of time
here so I'm gonna let you run Avi thank
you so much for taking the time to come
out here was it great the great
conversation and uh thank you very much
my pleasure all right thanks for hosting
me uh see you guys on Monday we'll be
back to our usual schtick next week
we'll be doing our live shows and
everything we don't have guests next
week do we Dan
uh not next week yeah so actually we
should maybe clarify you had misspoke on
the last episode about Howie being next
week it's not next week it's the
following week okay
anyway guys have a great weekend we'll
see you on Monday take care everybody
bye
[Music]
thank you